hey everybody and welcome to an
explosive wild ride with stevo this is
the first that anybody has heard from my
dear friend bam margera in quite some
time
and with that said there's been a lot of
rumors and conspiracy theories and crazy
stuff swirling around bam and i'm
thrilled that you're gonna be able to
hear from bam
what really has been going on and as we
go into this i would love to set the
record straight that number one bam has
not ever been under a conservatorship
that the temporary guardianship he was
under did not ever have any financial
implications and what's come to be known
as the free bam movement has really been
very toxic it's served to try to
assassinate the character of bam's
former guardian lima who has never been
paid to
work on bam's case has never done
anything but try to help bam and it's
been very upsetting to see people not
only encouraging bam to leave treatment
and go get loaded but just attacking
this woman who's been so helpful and so
beloved by bam's family and friends
so i just wanted to set the record
straight on that also this episode was
recorded a while back and we held on to
it until now
and with that said
let's get into it
may god have mercy on our souls ladies
and gentlemen bam margera
yeah man here i am in orlando florida i
got a break from treatment center in uh
boca raton but i'm at the dalton canaan
and destin durham triplets they got a
half pipe out back and uh phoenix is
super stoked because he's going to
tomorrow we've taken care of letting
man i disney
everybody know where you are
let's put your social security number up
on next if you don't know
yeah
but i'm not stoked because i went
skating for the first day and some
little poison [ __ ] ass waxed a half like
pooping like an iceberg eskimo and like
a penguin i went
it broke my wrist and elbow my wrist was
like a shape of an acid my bone was
practically popping out the back they
gave me the [ __ ] to kill michael jackson
and knock me straight out put it back in
the place like he could not be awake for
this [ __ ]
um [ __ ] yeah
the
honest truth i think is bam that we've
reached an age where our bones break way
more easily oh yeah this is my 11th
wrist break on this one
wow eleventh on that wrist
i think i think the only thing left to
break is my my right clavicle uh my left
clavicle is ready to get some hardware
out
because i got 16 staples in the head
from cracking my head open from uh
filming the bloodhound gang uh um
cribs episode and then um
i got eight broken ribs four broken ribs
then i got
um
four broken wrists 11 broken wrist
broken elbow twice now and then um
three broken feet over here i've broken
every finger and every toes
numerous amounts of times broken
tailbone with socks
tailbone was when they showed your
wiener on mtv huh yeah my two inch hose
all right um
so dude
let's just come out and say it that
us having this conversation
is
[ __ ] explosive
like almost radioactive some people i
mean like that the interest in
people hearing from you
people hearing seeing us together is off
the charts
i did a year of alcohol treatment and i
actually have never felt better i
actually didn't realize i had such a
problem that i did and uh dude or do
that's a distinction that we need to be
clear about yeah i guess do um because
novak said dude if you just do a year
you'll understand how much better you
will feel because you always go 30 to 60
days maybe 90 tops but if you just do a
year you'll understand and i call them
up after you i'm like novak i understand
i get it i feel great now you know i i
do not want that lifestyle i got a
four-year-old i don't miss the hangovers
whatsoever
and uh i just don't want to return to
that anymore
okay
and i think that that is
is is very good
um i also
i have to be honest that i'm concerned
that uh
i get the impression that you feel like
all right i'm done you know i did my
year of treatment and now i'm done and
now i can kind of get back to running
around and doing my own thing like i
worry like crazy that you feel that the
problem you have with alcoholism is
something that you can handle on your
own
well i still have 90 more days of class
but i'm going to transfer to carl's bed
to finish the classes but they they
still drug test alcohol tests do every
time i go right i mean just to give you
um an idea of what it was like for me
i remember
understanding the
statistics for alcoholics staying sober
they are not in our favor bam most
alcoholics die drunk of causes related
directly to alcoholism and i i've heard
that only like five percent make it and
when i went into rehab i was like dude i
want to be in that five percent and i'm
willing to do whatever it takes to give
myself the advantage and that's why i
lived in the little halfway house to
protect my sobriety i stayed in the
little halfway house until i was two
years sober and only then when i left
the halfway house
even then i i needed to live like next
door
to like a sober guy because i wanted to
protect my sobriety so much you know
like
and uh it's just important to really
really
protect it and i say that as a guy who
loves you man like uh
you gotta know yeah
you know it's not my job to say who's an
alcoholic or who's not but i think that
we can agree
oh yeah yeah i know dude i've been i've
been going for it for 10 years or more
like
there would be breaks and [ __ ] but i
mean
there were times i would just wake up to
whiskey and hot
sure
and
with god
all day long when i'd wake up with a
hangover you know
sure and and every time there was a
break
without fail whenever you took so much
as one sip of alcohol
then the whole gorilla came out of the
cage you open that door one little crack
and the whole gorilla comes out of the
cage and you can't get the gorilla back
in the cage yeah and not to mention if i
ever made skating plans or workout plans
i'm like dude all bets are off i'm
drinking like for some reason when i'm
drinking all activities are off i just
like to sit at home or whatever crack
jokes watch tv whatever but i mean i'll
paint and stuff but i'm i'm not
productive like skating wise or working
out wise i just don't feel like it right
and what was so hard was it hard to
admit that you had a problem or was
there so because um
man because i i
i wasn't like going out and being a uh i
wasn't going out to bars and i wasn't
being a mess
so um
the fact that i learned how to control
behaving myself but still being wasted i
felt like i i had an excuse to say i'm
better
than i was can you help enlighten us as
to what period you're referring to when
you were able to control
being
yeah i mean dude those days are so long
gone bam like you didn't control [ __ ]
well i i've tried every witch method i'm
like all right i'm only gonna sip on
weight claws from now on yeah then i'd
be like all right i'm only going to sip
whiskey just very
every so once in a while that didn't
work out all right i'm just going to do
white wine during dinner you know that
didn't work
i've tried it all and i i figured out
that it just always turns into one glass
turns into two then it turns into a
bottle turns into two bottles and i'm
out looking for booger sugar sure
i mean
and i think that we've we've established
that over and over again and the other
thing too
is that
by definition
an alcoholic can't keep himself sober
you know that's why we have this
community
of people who
keep each other sober and we stay sober
by helping other people stay sober and
i'm telling you man that like the the
secret to success
as an alcoholic is to join
this team and do what we do well that's
why i liked when i packed up everything
and i moved to san marcos in southern
california because i had such a tight
group of skater friends that were sober
i navid the shaman who i was hiking with
all the time eight miles a day sometimes
five at five in the morning it was like
a ritual and then um i was doing the
shackler meetings all the time i was
doing your wednesday meeting um your
home group
and um
it was just working out then i twisted
my ankle at tony hawk's house then from
all there it was just downhill i'm like
i'm getting my six-pack of [ __ ] white
claw then then it turned into 12-pack
and then i just started sitting around
and drinking and i'm particularly
nervous
like right now and this is the reason
why i wanted to talk to you right now is
because you've got like a whole year
that you've been in treatment you're
really like a good sort of distance from
your last drink and i feel like if that
if the idea crawls into your head that
you can get away with having a sip on
some kind of a drink and then the whole
gorilla comes out of the cage again like
i really i don't want to do that anymore
and one should not want to do drugs much
less smoke cigarettes or vape you know
as a society we are at a point where
people look upon smokers and vapers as
losers i said it and i don't think you
want to be a loser i personally could
not be more thrilled that i quit smoking
cigarettes well over 10 years ago now
and i am even more thrilled that the
wild ride podcast is here to help you
quit cigarettes and or vaping how
because we've teamed up with fume it's
this company that is just kicking butt
in the quit smoking department it they
make
wooden
inhalers that are handcrafted that have
cores which are infused with plant oils
which are proven to help with cravings
and help you quit now how do you get it
you go to breathe fume dot com
stevo that's b r e a t h e
f u m
dot com slash devo by doing that and
using the promo code stevo you get 10
off your entire order and man they've
got these things so dialed in with just
great flavors like cozy chai
screw the vaping screw the
the tobacco screw the nicotine there is
no nicotine in fume products because
they don't need it these plant oils are
getting the job done and getting it done
well as proven by thousands of five star
reviews from very happy
new non-smokers slash born again winners
so let's get you off the stupid vape and
the stupid tobacco get you on fume by
going to breathe fume.com
devo use the promo code stevo to get 10
off your order and
love life as a winner now let's get back
to it
yeah i feel like it's really scary after
everything you've been through over the
last year two years that if you drink
again and and the whole gorilla comes
out then we've got a serious problem on
our hands yeah and plus i've done a year
without a phone i haven't had internet
privileges i haven't had music privilege
because all the music's on my phone so
like
once i turn my phone on and everybody
knows i did a year sober i have all
these business opportunities that i do
not want to [ __ ] up it's kind of like
when novak um
got the opportunity to work for banyan
treatment center and he got a really big
paycheck that he's like oh my god you
know like he knows that if he sips on
even a glass of wine and banyan finds
out he's [ __ ] forever so like he does
not want to ruin his relationship with
banyan he's making great money and he's
helping people right you know good and
and like
with this now i have a brand new phone
number so i l when viva la bam days and
just my drunken days i let so many
people in my bubble that it just [ __ ]
exploded so many drinking buddies so
many
people just yo let me get your number
like if i had a good time with you that
night he'll let me get your number yeah
sure whatever and everybody would blow
me up on the phone that i didn't even
know who was important and who to answer
to anymore now i got a tight group of
friends that i talk to on the daily you
know i don't if somebody says can i get
your number i say nope you know i i just
keep it real tight talk to danny way on
the regular yellow off on the regular
you um you know the derns novak um kat
von d you know i love that and i gotta
say i gotta say i'm really grateful that
you and i have
maintained a friendship particularly
throughout everything that that's gone
on with jackass yeah and um
and i i really really want you to know
that
even though i don't think you you choose
to believe it the fact is that the whole
you getting your contract canceled or
whatever you want to call it kicked out
of jackass 4
was was genuinely the same
as
me getting an intervention from johnny
knoxville you know like the scene
but i got so much to say like in jackass
2 i got
if i've got drunk at the lax airport
with brass knuckles i got a [ __ ]
felony charge and i got high five for
good press now i wind up sipping on a
beer out front of a hotel on tmz and i
get kicked out for for being a liability
it's just [ __ ] ridiculous
okay
i mean i'll
entertain
some of that and and back in the days of
jackass number two we were in our heyday
we were at our worst drugs and alcohol
were still working for us nobody was
getting locked up in rehab or jail or
like just you know having public
meltdowns and i i hope that you can
understand that at a certain point
like specifically over the last few
years that it stopped being fun
it stopped being funny it stopped being
cool it stopped being something that we
want to give give you a high five for
because we're like we've been watching
you
self-destruct i will say specifically
tremaine and knoxville
saved my life by
enforcing
some
some consequences like if somebody does
this they made me want to jump off the
tallest building on the planet
okay be careful with seeing things like
that because that triggers 5150s and
saying i want to i said
that's why i got in my position because
i said
well i said if i don't see my kid if
he's not on that airplane
then i'm going to jump off a bridge or
something right and then i got marshman
acted in florida which means you have to
do 90 days or something and i said have
you ever seen my movies i jump off of so
many bridges in the bushes and pools you
[ __ ] idiots i didn't mean i was gonna
kill myself right so
i did madero beach on the on the west
side and i made it 75 days i had 15 days
left they're like bam you've been
rocking the same sweatpants for 75 days
i'm like yeah i'm not trying to get any
[ __ ] [ __ ] around here i don't give a
[ __ ] and like well you're getting kicked
out for bad hygiene i'm like oh my god
so i get to another place in ocala
national forest so i'm like so this is
day 76 they're like oh no you're
starting to square one i'm like
[ __ ] so i make it to day 80
there and i smoke a cigarette and i
throw it out and it's smoking in a bush
and they film it they're like you could
have lit the whole national forest on
fire you're getting sent to west palm
beach i'm like what the [ __ ] now i know
i'm getting back to square one that's
why i've been doing this [ __ ] for a year
okay
and i did 111 days there and i wanted to
get transferred to florida because it
was just a better option until i figured
out that the marksman act only happens
in florida
okay now what concerns me about i mean
by the way the stories are hilarious
getting kicked out for a bad hygiene and
for trying to light a forest on fire
both very funny anecdotes but the that
what concerns me about that is that you
describe it as oh and that sent me back
to square one the clock and so i had to
start over and and it was longer before
i could be done you know and and i i
would just want to impress upon you that
it's not about a beginning and an end
it's about learning a new way to live
and and that new way to live is really
it's important that that we don't blame
everything on everybody else and and
assume that no i know but i already knew
i already knew in arizona that i wanted
to
end it and be over with with alcohol
better off drinking water like i do with
my liquid death come on this is a
company that's saving the world baby you
got infinitely recyclable aluminum cans
because plastic is destroying the world
get hip to it man liquid death it looks
like you're drinking a beer but you're
not you're drinking water straight from
the alps and it is good water dude plus
they're hooking you up man if you go to
liquid death.com
stevo then you get free shipping on all
of your orders of water and merch and
let's be clear
shipping water i mean water weighs a lot
you know you're gonna get
cases of this awesome water and not have
to pay for shipping very generous of
this wonderful company liquid death
jump on this right now by going to
liquid death.com
stevo free shipping on all of your water
and your merch and wait until you see
their merch it's hysterical it's killer
so yeah i love liquid death go get some
at liquid death.com
stevo now
but i had to finish my time
and and i
it just sucks that i had 10 more days
left and i was done
but i got transferred and i had to do 90
again and then transfer and do 90 yeah
like what is this going to end so now it
finally ended
now um yes but but now i have to just do
outpatient treatment in florida until
july 17th then i'm gonna move to
southern california and and just do iop
which is just classes three days a week
okay good and when and when you uh
come to california
like
aside from the classes
iop see when that ends like once all of
the treatment is done like what's your
plan for protecting your sobriety
just go to meetings hang out with sober
people get a sponsor maybe conrad i
really liked him at scheckler's place
i love it
i love it i mean dude like uh that's the
first time that you've ever
said anything that sounded like you you
had some willingness to to join the team
and and it's borderline inappropriate
and my phone is just
programmed with a very select few of
just sober people i love it like nobody
else it's just all
sober friends or family i love it and i
don't let anybody else in
there's nothing that i won't do or novak
like any of our sober buddies there's
nothing we won't do to help you stay
sober yeah
yeah i found myself really a lot more
productive i would let days go by
without answering important people which
probably [ __ ] up a lot of business
deals like this [ __ ] hasn't answered
for a week let's let's just do the
clothing line with somebody else or
whatever you know
right
so
let let me ask you you said about this
living without your phone living with
all these like
um
what what's been going on with that
because i've seen a lot of activity on
social media with the hashtag freebam
and people seem to think that you're the
britney spears of jackass the evil
villains have taken over your life and
stolen all your money and like can we
safely say that none of that is true
i i don't know what's been going on
because i haven't been able to look
as a matter of fact i can't even post on
my instagram everything has to go for
johnny schiller from heart supply
because i had to sign a contract because
when i was dealing with the lawsuit with
paramount and jackass i was posted she's
like [ __ ] these [ __ ] and it was
potentially ruining my lawsuit so i had
to sign a paper saying that only johnny
can clear what goes through my instagram
so i don't even know my new passcode i
can't control what goes on it can i tell
you i think that's good news
and
i couldn't be trusted with the laptop
computer until i had been completely
sober for nine months and even then it
was a little bit questionable so yeah i
think that having that filter
you know i think i i think that's
absolutely great news and i hope to
because i think that the looking at your
social media since you got out of
treatment it's feeling a lot more like
you when you were in treatment it didn't
it was [ __ ] obvious that that was not
ban posting it was not in your voice it
it was like oddly
like sort of masquerading as
you but it wasn't you and it seemed kind
of ingenuine and it's starting to feel
more genuine so i get the sense that
you're participating in what goes out
yeah i i i still haven't looked to see
what has happened but now that i have my
phone back i just shoot photos send it
to schiller f and if he likes it or
whatever then he'll post it
yeah that's good man because dude it's
it's tough to see some of that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that you were posting man
well at the time i just figured
instagram should be real because
everybody's posting stuff like at the
beach when my buddies having a blast at
the blah blah blah having a blast i'm
like why can't it be like this [ __ ]
backed into me and i'm having a [ __ ] day
you know like
like that's why if you know if i'm
having a problem i'm gonna post it you
know like and and i guess that's not the
case because it's like bam's at it again
you know yeah the problem is that it was
very real and what was real was that you
were having a [ __ ] meltdown
you know like you could have used a
little bit of uh less real
yeah yeah
maybe a post at the beach would have
done nice
right
at the beach with your buddies
when i first checked into the last we
have i i made sure i was an eight plus
student i showered i shaved i [ __ ]
folded my clothes i did my laundry but
my first roommate was this dude named
patrick this portly dude who and the
first thing i do i'm like ew patrick you
took a millionaire [ __ ] and didn't even
flush the toilet what's not my fault the
twilight people and then he smokes a
cigarette the ashtray is right [ __ ]
there and he just puts it out in the
wicker chair and melts it throws in the
bush i'm like patrick the ass [ __ ]
trains right there what is not my fault
i'm smoking a cigarette and i'm like
patrick you didn't even do the dishes
you [ __ ] slob what it's not my photos
cooking a hamburger like nothing is his
fault at all wow
then my next roommate was kyle and he's
like oh so you're from philly i'm from
newark delaware is that close to him
like yeah it's 15 minutes like yeah you
know that's 7-eleven in newark i'm like
i don't know maybe he's like i used to
ride my bike past there i'm like great
story kyle and i'm on the phone i'm
moving this phone call i'm like yeah so
anyway he's like yo bam you ever seen
nutty professor i'm like
i don't know maybe he's like yeah this
one guy forget what character but he
said this one thing it was hilarious i'm
like
great story kyle can you tell me that
one again
it's like a sick time
bam
bam uh you said that that you haven't
been able to see any of the stuff that's
been going on on social media and i
think that that's probably a blessing
you know [ __ ] what goes on on social
media there's nothing that we need to
see there but
from your perspective of what you have
seen and what your experience has been
over the last year can we safely say
that you have not been a prisoner
and mistreated and like you know
like stolen from
like like the the whole help us
understand your situation no i i've i
was just getting treatment for my
alcohol and bipolar
and um
and i i just did more time than i was
supposed to just from getting kicked out
for dumb reasons but
um now i'm i'm out i get freedom i get a
phone and uh nobody was forcing me to be
there and um there's this really crazy
lady that i know who has been like
posting my guardian's number on my aunt
missy nick don pierre's proxy and like
has just been on a
prowl just making up so many lies she
has now has a lawsuit by five different
people that are my friends or family
that and i think she's even a [ __ ]
lawyer or something but but that's why
she can get the dirt of everything she
has footage of me barfing in the back of
the police car she has footage of me
getting handcuffed out of this nice
hotel in in madero beach when when i had
a i was going to surprise nikki in
phoenix at a joint room at the top suite
until i forget what the name was but as
soon as i went in to surprise knock him
and surprise him the cops were already
there to arrest me and i was on a couple
white claws i wasn't out of control but
they handcuffed me and said you're
getting baker acted for saying you're
going to jump off a bridge or whatever
i'm like oh my god i couldn't relate
what's the baker actually cracked is
just florida's version of a 5150 yeah
same exact thing and yeah sorry so steve
the britney spears thing like that was a
conservatorship and this is different
very different indeed we will get into
the specifics but let me give you the
broad stroke there are financial
implications in a conservatorship and
perhaps even more substantial financial
implications in being a businessman
selling your own merch online with
shipstation like for example these
killer shoes they're never going to
exist again i mean the only way to get
them is at stevo.com
just like this skateboard only way to
get it's at stevo.com and when people
order these things from stevo.com you
know how we ship them with shipstation
what is it it's this easy to use
interface that brings in all the
different methods of selling maybe you
use amazon maybe you use etsy maybe you
got your own website it's one interface
where you can do all of your shipping
from that one interface and it brings in
all the different carriers like the
united states post office ups fedex plus
it gives you the best prices from all of
those care carriers which are normally
reserved for fortune 500 companies and
even better news you're gonna get a
60-day free trial to see how well all of
this works if you go to shipstation.com
in the top right corner you click the
microphone you plug in the promo code
stevo and boom you got a 60-day free
trial that is 60 days of absolutely free
hassle-free shipping with all these
great prices with all this easy to use
interface i mean dude your time is
valuable man and like i said there are
major financial implications in building
your own online empire
if you're already selling stuff online
then use shipstation because you're
going to be more cost effective you're
going to be more efficient you're going
to make more money and if you're not
selling stuff online then get hip to it
man because
there's money to be made just check out
how much we're doing at stevo.com so
become your own boss get an online
empire going use shipstation make ship
happen
at shipstation.com
microphone on the top right hand corner
use the promo code stevo
now let's talk about this
conservatorship nonsense
britney spears had a conservatorship
which has financial implications in
which like she had no control of her own
money and other people could spend their
own money and despite like people
conspiracy theorists online trying to
say that that uh a guardianship is the
same as a conservative ship it's not and
nobody has taken control of your money
bam can we confirm that
yeah absolutely
my dad is my accountant and it goes
nowhere else but his his pockets
that can help shut up a lot of noise
that is very counter
productive very destructive and just
[ __ ] and thank you for clearing that
up and if i hear you correctly what's
happened over the last year is that
you've gotten help which you acknowledge
that you need
the good news is
like if my dad was to rip me off he
doesn't like sports cars or fancy cars
he's too fat to fit in a ferrari all he
likes is cheesesteaks and hoagies and
elvis memorabilia which he already has
all of it i don't think there's anything
left that he doesn't have so he doesn't
[ __ ] want anything so okay if he's
gonna rip me off go ahead like you know
like he he's the perfect person to
handle my money because he he's just not
the type of person that needs prada
shoes and [ __ ] you know he doesn't care
he definitely loves you too
so
let's talk about some fun [ __ ] because
um you and i were going back and forth
on texts and uh
i you know you you're excited about
moving out to california and let's do
some [ __ ] together
let's create content and i'm super
excited to help you
create content and [ __ ] you know blow
up on youtube
i've been super excited to help you
you know yeah i'm stoked that you got my
yeah you got my youtube back because
this idiot leon hill was pocketing so
much money from me i found out i didn't
know your youtube back i i created it
you would not give me
yeah but he would not give me the
password to it because um
he i think he got eighty thousand
dollars from it and um and i
it was just a big mess but um so what's
the news forking it over
i remember seeing yeah but i have a lot
of good stuff for the new youtube
channel so um thanks for hooking that up
for me but what ass text do we have i
was just looking at it it says stevo i
just jerk i was trying to jerk off in
the shower i slipped and fell and i hurt
my ass i'm flying you in with a mitten
on to throw me a bone here you're like
who needs a mitten
what is that he said put on a minute put
on a mitten and jacked me off admitting
because i thought that she needed that
gay if you have a mitt you have a glove
on
well who needs a mitten i'll just do it
anyway now that i'm still i think
there's some confusion around this this
youtube channel situation i
understand that i created
a youtube channel for you but after i
did that i saw on your instagram that
you had a channel linked in your
instagram bio and i'm just like what
what's going on i don't understand i'm
confused but
didn't we get the slash bam margera or
something like we did
i don't know so it's not like you got
the channel but you see the problem
everybody handles
everything on social media for me so
at the moment can't control my instagram
facebook has been long gone that's fine
and it's better to bank good content you
know i don't know yet because you just
started it but like everything is just
out of my hands
which is fine
i which is fine if
at this point bam if you can worry about
one thing which is get through the day
without drinking alcohol or taking drugs
and pull that off then every day is a
good day
don't worry about anything else
and um yeah and when you get out here i
i love the idea of us being active
together making dope ass videos working
on
your live show which you've already
begun to work on
and uh yeah you know and stay sober and
be productive be productive be focused
and
you know come back because like i've
told you
all along you can't pretend to be
in recovery
it's just it's it's completely [ __ ]
obvious like you either are or you
aren't and uh and and i want that for
you to really be in recovery everyone
will see it it'll be a whole new bam and
alcoholism is the only [ __ ] disease
where when you treat it and recover from
it you become a better version of
yourself than you were before it's any
other disease the best you can hope for
is to be as good as you were before
but this one makes you better
and i can't wait for you the worst part
was um
you know i had to go a year without
seeing phoenix and the age of four
the age of four is such a
fun age and i missed it all and i just
feel like i have so much
lost time to make up for and i just want
to play with him and teach him
everything i know and just make up for
the [ __ ] year that i missed
you know um
you know and i don't want to spend any
time
wasting time at any bars or anything
anymore i've done that
far too long
don't need it anymore hey can you can
you talk about your live show what do
you have planned what are you working on
what's it going to be like
yeah well at the moment um
me and johnny schiller from heart supply
are really kicking in with uh doing
decks and clothing and um you know tech
decks are sold at target right now and
um
and then me and yellow wolf he started
gold tooth clothing and um we're doing a
collaboration with all my
you know he looked at my book and saw
all my jackass ideas he's like these are
hilarious we're doing a t-shirt line
with this you know so um so we're just
doing a little collabo with that and
danny way and yellow wolf are doing this
5150 psycho elixir drink that they want
me involved
i'll do and um
you know when i was in rehab i was
wondering why i had a nutritionist and i
wasn't losing any weight and i found out
that my one roommate big ben he's like
i'm like have you always been this big
he's like no i gained a hundred pounds
in here i'm like wow he's like from zip
practice and depakote i'm like that's
what the [ __ ] i'm on i'm like doc why do
you give me a psychological duplicate i
told you i'm depressed because i'm top
heavy and i can't skate and he's like
well it's an antidepressant i'm like but
i'm getting more depressed you idiot
so i got off that and i was dropping a
pound a day so um so to answer
that so once i get to the weight that i
want to live show then i'll start um
you know
so the live show is coming together
great and we're talking about the idea
of uh of you coming on tour with me to
try out your new material uh at the
opening of my show oh yeah
do we know what city is that i wrote a
lot of funny material we don't know
anything about i don't know if i want
and also i have this really good idea
i've been working with with joe devito
from uh viva la bam he directed that
with nitro circus he worked with but um
i wanted to do this thing called the
earth rocker awards where i show up to
first i want to do it with musicians
rappers and rock stars and give i don't
trash your place i cash your place i
knock on the door i give you an earth
rocker trophy we film a day in the life
you know maybe throwing some jackass
type [ __ ] stunts and funniness in there
but um i film a day in the life i find
out what kind of new music you're up to
and whatever and maybe we could do it
with skateboarders or or artists you
know like painting artists that i like
or um whatever but i think musicians
would be the way to do it first because
i just have a lot of new fans that no
one knows about who needs to know about
because
i'm just sick of hearing the same old
radio [ __ ] when there's bands to be
heard
like i i've heard it all i've been all
over the world and there's so many radio
hits that could be hits but they're just
signed to a german
label or something that's why you don't
hear of
right did we ever get bam's album
blasted out of the last one your
eavesdropper album i'll say it again is
so
goddamn good where is that
can people get that download i love it
thank you
yeah dad i
i absolutely can't get enough of that
yeah i feel like is it on youtube or
someone put it i'm really proud of that
album um it's called the eavesdroppers
and it's
you could you could hear it on youtube
but um
uh i don't know why my brother hasn't
put it on itunes yet um i should
actually call him up and figure that out
but uh i think he's the type of dude
that wants to make a limited edition of
vinyl pressings and just make it really
um for die hard
yeah put me in for one because i want i
worked really hard on that album
yeah i'm really proud of that album and
um
it's it's fantastic oh these droppers
right there oh yeah
oh you've got it eavesdropper dad get
yeah [ __ ] dude we
recorded it we recorded that in iceland
and we did it my brother bought prince's
sound board from the purple rain era and
now my castle bam is a recording studio
and my brother lives there he's had
clutch in there a kill switch engage um
uh danko jones everybody wants to go
there now because it's eight bedrooms
that that are empty and they've got
four-wheeler trails and four is a
skatepark if they want to skate so i
mean it's perfect for rock bands to want
to stay and be creative wow and just
have a big 14 acre field to just you
know relax like a pool hot tub all that
[ __ ] so totally right
castle bam studios
how many of those copies that you're
holding are there right there because i
want one of those i think i think yeah
i'll definitely send you something but i
think we just did a pressing of ten
thousand okay what definitely uh yeah
hooked me up and can i just say bam that
i just wish i could just give you a hug
i wish i could somehow
just
transmit
some kind of energy that would protect
you
and and make you healthy and happy
because i [ __ ] love you bro
yeah i gotta say man you are always
stuck by my side throughout all this and
i gotta thank you for that
i appreciate it um
you know any time i was really down in
the dumpster having a rough patch you're
always there to be by my side and i i
can't thank you enough
well [ __ ] man i love the hell out of you
dude i really do
and i find it particularly interesting
too that
when i was there
like i never sugarcoated anything i
always told you like how it was
and i'm like the only person who didn't
get in trouble with you
for
telling you what you didn't want to hear
and um i just re i just i appreciate
that i'm grateful for that and um like i
said i just wish i could hug you and
transmit some kind of energy i feel like
we're closer now than than when we're
filming jackets actually
i mean for sure and like
we can also let the record reflect that
when you had been kicked out of the
movie that i was like oddly surprisingly
like campaigning to get you back in the
movie and we were so close bam we we had
to a point where yeah remember we were
so close we had
i was like writing scripts for you be
like tell them this say this and it's
gonna help get you back in the movie and
we got you to a point where you had a
zoom call with johnny knoxville spike
jones jeff tremaine and that was
specifically the call where they were
gonna make the decision you were all but
back in and you got loaded and missed
the [ __ ] call you you got loaded and
no showed the call and and they had to
see you once what happened was
yeah i didn't have a computer and i was
rushing to danny wade's house and
right
but they had to see you all wasted on
social media the night before so they
knew exactly why you missed the call and
they were like [ __ ] you know we were
this close to letting them back in but
he made the decision for us
and i was fighting so hard for him
everything meant for a reason and i i'm
much better off not being in it i'm very
happy to not be in it i didn't i don't
want to do that anymore i don't want to
be a part of it i i'm much happier
without it everything happens for a
reason and and uh you're grateful for
where you're at that's the best thing
i've heard you say this whole [ __ ]
time man and uh i i i i was fighting for
you to be in the movie it didn't work
whatever everything worked out in the
end
you're uh happy now that it's done on
and over with i i i didn't want to do it
in the first place and when when i did
my year of treatment i
had to figure out how to be
social again without alcohol i had to
learn how to not be bored again without
alcohol and and it i'm glad i actually
did a year because if i would have done
anything less then i might not have
figured out how to cure my boredom and
be social looking back on like when
you're in there in the year and like you
know trying to find your part in all
this did you did you have a problem like
did you find out what your part in this
whole situation was
part in in what part
and like how
were you able to accept any
responsibility for ending up in a rehab
yeah i mean
yeah i was a [ __ ] i am an alcoholic you
know like
um i have been for a long time uh
i remember when i was probably
24 i was so mesmerized by villavalo from
him
that you know he would just walk down
the street in finland and girls would
literally faint sometimes guys too so i
would just follow his lead i'm like he's
buying a pack of cigarettes i'm buying a
pack of cigarettes
getting a beer i'm getting a beer he's
doing a shot of sambuca i'm doing a shot
to say
then like once he cracked open a beer
when he woke up that was the first time
i'm like you're drinking in the morning
in the daytime he's like yeah why not uh
he's like you want one i'm like well i'm
not gonna let you do it alone but this
is [ __ ] crazy it was the first time i
ever day drunk drank and uh
that that's when i just
you know i thought it was crazy to be
drunk in the day or even drink a beer in
the day i just thought it was a friday
night thing you know
am i correct that that villa vallo is
sober for like a long time now yeah yeah
he uh
i think it's probably
six seven years now but i i know that
like occasionally he'll have a beer or
two with an old pal but um nothing more
than that he won't do any kind of
all-nighters or shots it'll just be a
beer or two to catch up with an old pal
what i've heard i don't know
that's what i've heard from
friends from finland
all right but it's very rare
okay
well dude i um
i gotta say i'm i'm super stoked that
you're where you're at now
and my only concern is keeping you where
you're at now
you know like
that's sober and healthy and happy
business opportunities like i feel like
there's progress being made and you've
done a lot just in this conversation to
indicate to me that you've made great
progress and that we're we're heading in
a good direction yeah i've been doing
five meetings a month or five meetings a
week every week
good that's good yeah yeah we miss
seeing you in san diego dude i know i
can't wait to get there man
yeah i really can't i'm excited for your
youtube channel too like are you for you
because i always tell people when people
ask me like about you or you come up in
conversation i feel a need to
tell people and remind people like you
kind of invented this [ __ ] like you were
playing around with your friends filming
[ __ ] editing your videos and
distributing them before youtube before
any of this [ __ ] so now for you
looking at youtube
like i don't know do you look at it like
i invented this [ __ ] kind of or like how
does it how does youtube strike you i
just
i knew that you know if if you look at
cky2k or cky1 it's something that you
could always watch because dude
skate video has just become so outdated
i remember watching plan b questionable
video over and over and over again
because it was just
such uncomparable to any other video it
was the best danny way was the best uh
it was just uncomparable and then
now it's just
they're getting better and better and
better and better and like if you even
watch questionable now it's just tricks
that kids could do for [ __ ] breakfast
right you know but i mixed in funny
ridiculous stunts in between pro skate
tricks so it never gets old you know
like
you're always gonna laugh and watch
great skating you know um which which
was completely
brand new to to
the whole skating sport and when i
played it to people that weren't
skateboarders and they were laughing
hysterical telling everybody everything
was through word of mouth it sold a
million copies you know like um
that that's why like you know
i mean tremaine always says big brother
story jackets well how come i sold over
a million copies and big brother only
sold like 80 000 or something like that
like he never gives me [ __ ] credit is
that what cky did out of the bootleg
tapes yeah we never had one ad and i
sold over a million of every single one
of them millions and millions of copies
yeah i mean everybody had cky 2k
ui was definitely
a huge deal you know yeah um
and
i agree with you there except for i
think we got to acknowledge that it was
knoxville and tremaine who reached out
to spike and got it going and then they
reached out to you saying hey do you
want to come on board with this thing so
how come how come spike jones has so
much say in jackass when he came in a
decade later
because he had the
the
clout the name the you know the the
power to make this
[ __ ] thing start nobody else would
have uh
if spike's name wasn't attached to
jackass in the beginning people would
have looked at it and said you can't put
this [ __ ] [ __ ] on tv no but wait a
minute but when jackass the first season
on mtv he he wasn't a part of it wasn't
it yeah he was absolutely oh he was for
sure and he also helped like shape the
look of the show a little bit yeah like
uh i did not know that i i just thought
ten years later he popped up
and then that was that the only the only
way they even got a meeting was because
spike was attached to it and i guess he
was just so m.i.a all the time i just
didn't know that he was even a part of
it spike was the one who opened the door
and i genuinely believed that without
spike people would have looked at the
footage that they were trying to sell
and said you cannot put this [ __ ]
reckless violent [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] on
tv like spike has made phenomenal movies
because spike's name was attached to it
it somehow
made what we do permissible for
broadcast television you know yeah i
know well i heard i heard the first
pitch to like hbo or something was like
we're not [ __ ] ever playing this you
crazy right and then i guess mtv was
like all right we'll give it a shot and
then like a light switch and spike was
in both of those meetings it was a
massive massive hit oh yeah oh yeah
so technically they did it
the funniest [ __ ] thing ever
they never made it though there's some
things that don't make it the jackass
and one of them was dave england was at
the venice beach
no no he was john pictures his own ass
he's like i'll take my picture drawn by
you for five dollars you sit there like
this only to reveal
her naked ass saggy tit with a
minion-ass [ __ ] and it just says [ __ ]
she's like you need church
they're like we will never ever ever
this is the best [ __ ] skit ever but i
agree this should never be aired on
television right
yeah
big an ass [ __ ] saggy just
i didn't know that that didn't air i
thought like i thought it did but either
way i remember it i remember it just
about as fondly as you do oh it's so
funny man yeah man well [ __ ] dude like
we've we've had uh a glorious
history man and and i'd like to think
that we're gonna have a glorious future
and for that to be the case i really
really want you to take seriously what
they're telling you in in these [ __ ]
classes that you still have to go to
because that's like been the the most
life-saving thing for me like my life is
good now because when i was in those
rehabs when i was in those classes that
outpatient [ __ ] that i really listened
to what the [ __ ] they said to do and i
followed their suggestions and
my life is really goddamn good because
of it and i want the same for you
yeah
so i i got you man i i
i've done
a year and i i get what novak was
talking about completely now good man
and and i love you and and by all means
man let's stay in touch the way we are
let's let's keep doing the [ __ ] thing
and when you get out here
let's
[ __ ] make it
better and better
and and then like when we're when we're
in a good spot let's [ __ ] go on tour
man
rock and roll i'm in all right brother i
love you man anything else you want to
say now uh like man mike tyson said this
to me today he said he pointed to the
cameras he said there's millions of
people watching right now what do you
want to tell them
i want to give a shout out to the derns
for um
letting me stay here and hook it up uh
vip tickets to disney
um they had to hook up and um
phoenix is just really excited and so am
i
all right man and uh we can tell
everybody to follow your social media
but you're not going to know about it
yeah bring it bring some of those cds
over to carlsbad i want to i want to
grab a couple yeah yeah i'll have my
brother mail them to you um i'll look up
the address to tight box yeah maybe we
can ship some out of type box too if you
get your now
[Music]
yeah
do that bring all ten thousand of them i
love that album man i worked really hard
on it it did it i worked really hard
unbelievable super stoked on it i don't
think there's one bad song on there yeah
bring all 10 000 to type box and we'll
get them out for you
yeah
we'll unload them in short order hey bam
you're the best i love you and uh
be healthy
[ __ ] listen to what they're telling
you in those goddamn rehab classes
yeah man all right
take care later
so there you have it we heard it from
the horse's mouth and
i think uh as i said in the intro this
was recorded with bam some time ago it
was back in may and
i'm sure a lot of you know that shortly
after
he
had some some issues where he where he
fled from from rehab well
he is
back in
rehab
and
i urge everybody please be supportive of
bam
being in rehab of taking sobriety
seriously because anybody who's talking
about free bam let them out get them out
of treatment like
you're trying to kill my
[ __ ] brother you know and don't do
that let's all please
be supportive of bam's sobriety and
that's it and thank you for sticking
around to the end
lots of love
[Music]